how's it going guys bat here with code
tech tutorials today we're just going to
look at some programmer humor and yeah
have some fun with it it's been a while
since i did one of these i usually do
something like this every thousand subs
or so and it's been more than that and i
kind of missed the 8 000 special video
so i guess this is it and we're just
gonna look at some
programming memes and humor and
it's basically gonna turn into explain
that humor and yes my glasses are messed
up don't worry i'm getting new ones soon
and okay so the meme about this program
or humor right now is that new
programmers come here and don't actually
understand the memes and just kind of
laugh at them like you know pretending
they understand them so we're going to
explain all of these at least as many as
i can manage to
all right and
so i recorded this i started recording
this about 10 minutes ago and then i
realized that my mic was off and i face
palmed really hard and started over so
lasai all right typical thoughts of
software engineers
all right 2020 this meeting could have
been an email yeah that's always really
annoying isn't it when
when people or your manager or whoever
is like we have a meeting i got an
announcement to make yeah you could just
email it
unless you need to have a discussion
around the subject that requires like
input now and you know critical time
limit all that probably don't need a
meeting i feel like there should be more
emails and less meetings in general
people get it
me you know emails are nice 2021 this
meeting could have been a simple chat
message this entire department could be
replaced with a
python script
you know things like discord and slack
and you know being able to just group
people and send a message it's so nice
all right well
can you really replace entire
departments with python scripts it
depends what they do
probably a lot of them truthfully i bail
on all a hobie who entered okay the soft
this is the software equivalent of a
message smeared on the walls and blood
dear programmer when i wrote this code
only god and i knew how it worked now
only god knows therefore if you're
trying to optimize this routine and it
fails most surely please increase the
counter as a warning for the next person
total hours wasted here 254 that's a lot
of hours okay
so
does this really need any explaining it
is kind of true
that once you write something really
complicated and you know it works and
you just kind of walk away and you know
you leave it as a function you're like
okay you do this thing just call this
function how does it work uh
well it's complicated so that's the
thing it's it's all about headspace you
can't keep really complicated things in
your head forever you usually need to
piece it in steps so
i don't know
i don't know where i'm going with this
other than yeah comments can be really
useful because of that type of thing and
you usually forget exactly what you did
later so and then
if you're the one who wrote it and
understood it and you're having trouble
understanding it again just imagine
someone who has no idea at all so this
this explains a lot all right that's
console gober debugging
console log here programmer's taking the
console log here
yeah you gotta debug sometimes though uh
you know console log actually works
pretty good the real problem with
console log
in my opinion at least is that it
muddies up your code basically and then
when you're like you know ready to move
forward and release it and you have no
there's no reason for console log to be
there debugging would have been better
and you can't really well i guess
there's some ways you can do it but it's
really hard to write tests with console
log because with debugging you can just
check what variables are and if they're
correct you know it's nice to get it in
errors and a nice test system so
debugging
i don't know where i'm going with this
kind of there's console lock here's not
that bad it's just it's a very novice
thing because
you just end up with really messy code
and having to think about a whole lot
more things with just debugging it's
just like break point where you think
the problem is see what the variables
are set to and then you don't have to
include more stuff and it's just
in the long run it's actually more
simple
to debug than it is to console.log it's
just when you're new and you don't
really understand debugging too well
console.log seems easier because at
least you understand that i don't know
if that's going to make sense to
everybody but that's my interpretation
of it instructions unclear got a dozen
milk bottles dear parents be aware of
the early signs that your child will
become a developer
write the following words in
alphabetical order the order they came
in an outfit okay so it's got a list of
words
oh he the kid actually rearranged the
word the letters in the word
apple a e lpp he rearranged each word
with the letters that come first now
that to be first that's kind of
brilliant but that is what the
instructions say isn't it right the
following words in alphabetical order
the order that came coming in the
alphabet
i could i can see how the kid
interpreted it that way but obviously
that's not what they meant that's that's
cool all right there we go yep
i'm a genius give me that promotion oh
[ __ ] please do not fire me at me every
few minutes this is pretty accurate okay
so this is a metronome metronome that
just ticks back and forth those that
need explaining
it's basically to keep timing for things
like drummers and musicians and stuff it
just takes back and forth so yeah
they're
explaining the meme
this is
what programming feels like a lot of
days sometimes you feel like you solved
a really hard problem that you're
surprised you know you're surprised
yourself that you could solve it and
then other days you get stuck on really
simple things that you're like how am i
getting stuck on this and then you
realize what the answer is and you're
like oh my gosh i've been working on
this for two hours and it's just one
little thing
yeah
it's it's interesting so what do you
make of this what do you do when this
happens i don't know
usually
uh when you're when you feel like
you're not understanding something you
either need to take a break take a rest
like a real rest or you need deeper
understanding so usually what i like to
do if i'm not understanding something
that i know is simple is well i guess it
depends on my level of motivation but
typically if i want to get to the answer
i need to go read or study more about
the problem in the underlying concepts
behind the problem and then like rest
and then usually it clicks later so and
if it doesn't it doesn't but yeah those
typical things and and just exercise to
going for a run or a walk can make a
pretty big difference too but sometimes
there's really nothing you can do except
time and keep working on it and
eventually it'll click and yeah yeah
you'll have that i'm a genius moment
more often but it happens it's pretty
normal even for really good developers
all right here we go i frequently have
this argument with my code my code
better start doing what i want instead
of doing what i'm telling it to do doing
what it wants to what i'm telling you to
do
okay
yeah it is really frustrating when you
know what you want your code to do you
code it up you feel like you got it
right but it does something else
you just gotta re go through your logic
sometimes
i don't know for me at least
sometimes when i think about something
and then i write it out in code and i
think okay perfect that's gonna do when
i actually run it does something
different usually there's just some
little logic error i made like i used it
and instead of an or something like that
or i have one thing in the wrong order
it shouldn't be happening yet or
something like that
[Music]
so this can be complicated but yeah
sometimes you just need to redo your
logic and think about it again i i don't
know what to say about it other than it
happens it goes along with this the same
meme basically
oh boy it's code review time typing
continuously for three years on the
homepage will crash the tab
what
typing continuously for three years on
the home page will crash the tab
three years how are you typing for three
years on a home that's crazy obviously
that shouldn't happen though it
shouldn't do anything
because the key should be ignored i
don't know what the program is but it
just sounds a little weird
all right here we go another meme i
prefer the cute way step debug
breakpoints big
big boy cat
it's kind of a chunky cast probably not
in the wild it's probably in a zoo or
something
console log here
i don't know why i'm interpreting that
out of the meme rather than the code
stuff but all right console log here
or the whole debug sequence
i don't know what else to say about this
the console log just looks ugly in
production you can't ship it like that
that's the real annoyance you know just
having to go remove all of those at some
point just to realize you might need
them again and then add it back in it
just makes things really complicated
when just the debug is is much easier in
general in the long run because you
don't have to worry about finding the
place to put console logging just
quickly go breakpoint what you're where
you want and step through it's the step
debug breakpoint is way easier actually
than console.log console.log is a lot it
causes a lot more brain power use than
this the main way there's a reason why
there's step debug and break points it's
because it is in the long run better
declare variables not war well just
notepad plus plus notes or uh version
declare variables down board make apps
not work
what is it with software developers
getting all political with their with
their uh development notes
it's like
they have something to say and don't
know where else to put it somewhat this
happened somewhere else recently too
with some game updates someone was
putting all these political messages in
their game updates i forget what game it
was
it just seems weird in my opinion what
are you doing
what's the point i'm going to be honest
when someone does this it makes me think
they have issues like like they need to
see a therapist or something it's like
do you not have anyone to discuss this
stuff with i mean i get it some people
are lonely but this is just not the
place
maybe they just need a place for it i
think the best thing to do honestly if
you're feeling like saying all this
stuff is probably to make a throwaway
anonymous account somewhere and say it
that way maybe i wouldn't maybe not even
that maybe that's not a good idea but if
you got to get it out somewhere but it's
like controversial political stuff you
don't actually want to attach to your
name because that's all you could do i
don't know i don't really care about
politics it's not my thing i think
they're kind of annoying
and
a waste of time all right and we get
paid for doing so what is this designers
look we have similar ideas no you stole
my idea programmers man i stole your
code it's not my code
oh okay that's pretty good yeah most
code is interpreted well not most code
depends what it is because you know if
you're writing your own unique thing and
you're not going off of anything except
for like
i don't know maybe the documentation of
how things work or well maybe you don't
even need that coding is a different
animal because
sometimes things are so hard that you
really you can literally can't figure
out how to do it until you see an
example and you're like oh perfect there
it is and you just copy paste because
white retyped the exact same letters
again so stealing code is definitely
different than stealing ideas in that
way but then again if it's a tiny little
snippet here and there it's a different
thing to like do a certain thing but if
it's a whole file that's when it's like
okay that's that's a bit much all right
when are we ever going to use this
learning quadratics calculus so i can
pass math and not tank by gpa relearning
calculus with nothing but google and
youtube to do something cool on a dumb
hobby scripting project kind of a hot
take here but
your dumb hobby scripting project is
more important than your gpa because
your gpa is like nothing it's just like
it gets thrown into a pool of okay
here's everybody's gpas but it doesn't
actually mean anything it doesn't go out
into the world nobody's ever to me never
to make use of that you're just doing
assignments that already have answers
with your hobby scripting project it's
probably a new unique thing that people
are gonna like actually have some take
away from so yeah it's actually way more
important and this is
this is another point i'm not sure
exactly how to make it but basically you
tend to learn and remember when you
actually have a use for the things
you're learning and that's that's the
problem with school in a lot of ways is
a lot of the stuff they're teaching you
you have no use for your your only
actual reason to learn it is to get a
grade and your grade doesn't really do
anything other than
you can put it on your resume and said
i'm this good at that thing based on
this grade whereas with the project
project just like here's
i wrote this i did this and i used these
concepts it's like
that's better than a gpa usually
or any score so
i don't know interesting interesting all
right well anyway let's move on relative
friends as soon as you tell them oh so
you like programming make me a website
then
okay it's home i tend to just ignore
friends and relatives asking me to do
stuff for them or saying oh i need i
have an idea you do this
i i don't even respond anymore because
it's always like
well they just drag it out they'll just
go on for hours and days and hours and
days and you're like just staring at
them like
what do you want from me you just want
to hash your idea out to me
just now it's a different thing if you
already know what you want and you're
like okay here's my design
can you do it
and
you know how much do you want to do this
or they make you an offer you know if
you just like get down to business and
say i want it done then awesome i'd love
to do it but if you just want to like
hash your idea back and forth forever
i'm not interested i'm here to program
not to listen to you babble about your
design just give me the design i don't
care what your design is
i can just program it i don't really
want to redesign your design or care but
yeah
i don't know if that makes a whole lot
of sense but it's really actually quite
frustrating when people want to just
talk design all day it's like i'm not a
designer i'm a programmer you give me
the design that you came up with and
i'll make it into a thing that works
i don't care what your design is i'm
just going to follow the instructions
that's all i want i just want to follow
the instructions i don't want to write
the instruction okay all right i'll move
on
but does anybody else feel that way all
right after debugging for two hours on
our program we finally fixed the bug
okay
yeah i guess uh
having a bug is kind of like falling
down when it gets i don't know
people just gotta find a way to use that
meme for everything that's that's all
there is to make it it does feel really
good to recover from an error or an
annoying bug or yeah i guess that's all
that means how
how can exist someone that can fully
understand how a script works just by
reading it what you can say the same
about that sentence all right when you
fully understand how a script works just
by reading it
i don't know what the problem is yeah
you do feel kind of cool don't you
yeah i can get it
man homer looks it looks pimped there
am i allowed to say that
all right probably last one
different grammars be like that when
programmers meet anti-grammars
at the office all right i'm gonna be
honest i don't get this one they what do
they mean by anti-grammars just
non-programmers just people that aren't
programmers why would you be hitting
them
i i i don't get it
anyone want to explain this to me
different grammar speed like that
i don't follow
i kind of get what they're going for i
think but geez if you think like this
like good luck getting a job
you're gonna be that one bitter person
that everyone's gonna be like can we get
can we get rid of old
sammy a real stick in the mud
no one wants to work with you don't be
that guy
all right
wondering what verse we will be praying
prayers and latin prayers here prayers
and
harambek prayers and
see
that's when you gotta bust out the holy
see all right i said last one but we
keep going good advice what would be the
best way to get a get into programming
for a noob
don't
[Music]
i don't obviously that's not a good
answer but i don't know i think just
pick some small projects
do a google search for small easy
programming projects and pick a language
and try to do them and
maybe get help from someone more
experienced and ask for a walk through
or controversial
go on youtube and type whatever language
projects
tutorial for beginners or something and
they there's so many tutorials out there
that'll walk you from steps from
absolutely no knowledge to some
completed small thing and those are
really great for getting an initial
launch point because you kind of want to
start to understand the setup what the
basic tools are you need and it's all in
walk through form and i make some of
those here on this channel so
it it actually kind of bothers me that
people ask questions like this because
the answer is so obvious and
yeah the answer is just really obvious
that's the answer to 90 percent of my
youtube comments is google it man why
are you asking me i'm not going to give
you a better answer than google will
probably not anyway that's you know not
always true but
but yeah 9 out of 10 times probably is
i think most people realize that all
right
last one for sure that's what my code
has to be like for me to consider myself
a senior if a equals equals true return
true else if
a equals equals false return false
do i even need to explain this one i
guess i will why don't you just return a
just return a all right that's that's
the joke here
because uh well that's with all the
comparisons it is what it is already
just return it and you got your true or
false
all right
ah that's it for this video thanks for
watching hope you guys are doing well
take care of yourselves and i appreciate
you guys so let's see in the next one
and uh peace out
and leave your ideas for videos down
below because i'm kind of running out or
series
and stuff alright peace guys
[Music]